I won't talk about any influences on the
movie because I got a real Halloween
vibe from it just from the way you did
yeah that is really cool that you got
that I'll tell you why okay go for it
you're gonna be very excited by it I'm
already excited that I'm very excited
perfect the first like seed of an idea
that I had when reading the script this
wasn't even in the script but this was
like an image that came in my mind was
was was and it's in the trailer now is
Brandon like flying out there in the
window like watching his mother through
the window that big wife from a distance
from a distance and Ana and and the idea
was shooting a superhero like John
Carpenter shoots Michael Myers you know
in those kind of like lurking wide
remember from Halloween said so so that
was like at the core seed of what I was
trying like where the vision goof-up I
mean but but you know look I grew up on
like Sam Raimi Peter Jackson movies
those guys are my heroes obviously I
love James I was before long before I
met James I was a fan of Dawn of the
Dead I was a fan of slither I knew him
when he made super but I'm a huge fan of
super so so you know there's a lot of
influences on this movie but but I grew
up a lover of horror movies I grew up
waiting in line to meet you know I stood
in line ten times to meet Wes Craven and
denene Clive Barker and to meet all
these guys so so it's crazy to be here
talking about my movie right now I'm
pretty excited
amazing I'm wondering just to jump off
that at that point what about those type
of horror movies lends itself to then
sort of blend with superhero
storytelling like where do those kinds
of movies meet in the middle with
superest or death sure um you know I was
just documentary a long time ago about
horror film creators in the movies that
they made in the classic horror movies
you know and it went into Nightmare on
Elm Street one of my favorite movies
noontime but it went into you know a
number of these movies and one of the
things that all those creators those
movies said is that is that so much of
what was happening around them at the
time influenced greatly what the movie
was you know some of those guys went
through Vietnam got traumatized by it
and you know and and and and then went
off to create these masterpieces and and
me you know right now is when we look
back on this time it's superheroes have
swallowed all of pop culture you know
and so it is just a natural progression
of of where things are gonna go to
create a horror film that is infused
with the superhero DNA to mashes those
things up you know I my goal in this was
to create a movie that took something
that you felt like so safe with like
superheroes that you always like like
believed in and grew up loving and turn
it into something that you were now
scared of in the same way that it took
you know a clown and did that so that
was really the goal it's interesting to
me because I this movies clearly you
know the inverse of the the super
Superman story and and it's always so
inspiring how Superman came to earth and
chose to do good but in this movie he
just you know I choose that he has his
power he's like well I'm gonna use it to
take over the area that I'm wondering if
that feels like to you a more realistic
scenario that a person discovers this
power and they they they it ruins them
instead of becoming a hero sure yeah I
mean we certainly play with superhero
tropes in this movie you mean and and
retell them through a horror lens you
know but I think that and then maybe
this is just the way I think but but if
if someone out there can hear me and and
finds an alien baby in the forest like
run for your life
don't raise on and on that alien do not
do that that is not a good idea and and
yeah I mean I think that you know
there's a lot of amazing family movies
that are made about superheroes that
that are full of hope and optimism and
and and altruism you know and we keep
seeing these stories where people get
superpowers and they go off and use it
for good and they get this great moral
lesson that teaches them how to use it
for good but but that just isn't this
movie this movie is about someone who
gets superpowers and uses them against
us I mean so lesson at the end do not
adopt the yelling it's it run run for
your life